better make some space on those ps4 Xbox
ones and PCs folks because evolved will
beginning a monstrous day one patch but
just how much storage space will it
devour how many monster puns can I fit
into one minute video find out in this
game spot news update evolved which
parent sees onto the scene worldwide on
februari 10th that's tomorrow we'll get
a patch on the same day weighing in at a
mammoth 3 gigabytes or thereabouts-- it
varies slightly by platform that the
patch is set to hunt down and ingest
Lord times B stop matchmaking a network
bandwidth optimization as well as
consuming several bugs discovered during
the big alpha and open beta as well as
balancing monsters and hunters but
that's not all the update will also
evolve the elite skins for hunters and
monsters based on feedback from the
community we've updated or outright
replaced the assets that we're already
in the game Turtle Rock said all you
need to do to unlock them earn them
that's all so have you been tracking
evolve wondering if you should gobble it
up and regurgitate it directly into your
computing machine well then why not
feast your eyes on our video review for
all you need to know for more tasty
video game news morsels make sure you
continue to stalk us right here on
gamespot com but not in a weird way